so Christ is King does that violate
verbally you said it you said it draws
attention it's provocative so now you
lean towards you want to satisfy the
audience my priori is I don't want to
violate anything in Islam he's correct
but he's misapplying
it Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping a reward click
the link and donate what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
sneo sneo is a new Muslim who is getting
to know the daene getting to speak to
different Brothers he met me Muhammad
haab Aki aan and many other people
alhamdulillah so he's in Dubai and he
wants to meet a few other people Subhan
Allah and he happens to come across
Faris obviously he doesn't know much
about him uh so it was just normal just
having a conversation with him but
obviously knowing Farris and I'm sure
everyone knows Farris I'm fasting as
well uh so I don't want to fall into
back byting but we guys know FIS we know
FIS for um laughing at the situation
what's happening in Gaza somebody who
blames the Palestinians for what they
are going through uh somebody who when
it comes to issue of boycotting just
mocks and laughs by it like you know
it's not big deal at all you know is
Comfort living in Dubai somebody who has
not said a single word against Israel I
wish I was on sneo stream I would have
asked him to ask Faris hammadi if he can
condemn Israel I would love to see that
but anyway so what does he do uh instead
of meeting sneo and you know uh giving
him some reminders in the sense of you
know just you know he's new to the D oh
no no no no no he has to straight to the
reputation mode uh sticks on him why cuz
he said Christ is King I said the same
thing as well yeah and he accuses him of
saying words of shik like again I'm
fasting now I don't want to fall into uh
backbiting if I'm fasting or not fasting
the the last person I want give my good
deeds is to Faris uh so sneo we spoke to
you and we told you about a group of
people who have an issue with everybody
he's one of them here is the video in
guys let's watch for ourself and see
what was his issue with sneo and what's
his evidence that the statement Christ
is King is shik how the hell is it shik
I'm the Jah ignorant one you're supposed
to be the knowledgeable one here yeah
you are the supposed to be the
knowledgeable one yeah how the hell is
saying Jesus is King and I'm I'm going
to say Jesus is King yeah and when he
comes back he will rule yes and there
will be peace he will be the king of all
Kings on Earth yes on Earth on Earth
they'll be rulership he rulership which
is the Sharia of the Prophet mhammad
peace be upon him he'll be following
that and he'll be ruling yes so how is
saying Jesus is King yes I understand to
say king of all Kings without giving
Contex say on Earth or whatever I
understand but he did not even say that
so let's watch for ourself inah see
what's this evidence to claim that to
say Jes Jesus's King Andrew Tate said
and him said makes him commit go against
to like you calm make this up I think
everybody has their their method in this
in this war against Shan yeah sorry but
proven what we were talking about social
media is a two EDG sword so Christ is
King does that
violate verbally not intentionally your
intention you don't believe Christ is a
king of kings because you wouldn't be
Muslim if you say that that I don't
believe that but you said it that is a
violation no he did not say it where did
he say Jesus is the king of King all
Kings he did not where did he say Jesus
is the king of all Kings you said to him
you don't believe Jesus is the king of
all Kings he said no I don't believe
that yes then you said yeah you said
that no he didn't and like you said
intentions for an action to be accepted
a deed you have to have the correct
intention and the action has to be
according to the Sunnah okay his
intention was there to for him to say
Jesus is King I don't understand how
does that how does that to deify him so
for example Christians say Jesus is
sinless yeah that that that makes him
God so if you come and say oh Jesus is
sinless does that mean now he said
because they believe sin is equation of
equating to God Only God Can Be sinless
yes so for them saying Oh Jesus is
sinless and I say well yeah Jesus
sinless and they go oh you see you said
well thank you yeah you believe Jesus Is
God no I don't so I don't understand
let's carry on so acts of worship has
two components has intention and act the
intention should be correct and the ACT
should be correct you can't say I have
my intention right but my ACT is not
right it's okay at least my intention is
right no it's Islam is not like that
because if you open that door then
anybody can do anything and says my
intention is right why you judging me
why you saying it's wrong you draw line
yeah where you so no acts of worship or
anything that's talked about in Islam or
in religion has to have these two
components that are right and so he's
correct but he's misapplying it he's
correct actions intentions have to be
there yes so I can't intend to give da
and then go to a nightclub cu the
actions that foll are not according to
the Sunnah yes then if I go to a
specific place where I want to give da
whatever what my intentions are for to
show off again it won't be accepted so
he's right but he's applying it to the
wrong place cuz sneo never said Jesus is
the king of all Kings and so you said it
you said it draws attention it's
provocative so now you lean towards you
want to satisfy the audience sorry I'm
not like putting on the spot no no good
yeah but but if you if you say no I
don't want to provoke anyone because
first of all my priorities I don't want
to violate anything in Islam if I don't
violate anything in Islam then yes I can
serve or fulfill my audiences true and
he said nothing that violates anything
in Islam he did not say anything that
violat in Islam what did he say Jesus is
King look I'm saying Jesus is King on
Earth okay he's going to be king or
Jesus is King like I'm justy yeah if I
said Jesus is the king of all Kings then
I'll say who what the Jesus used that
very specific word but he did not say
that I don't get it
I don't know curiosity or whatever
that's fine but then here's the line so
Christ is King no you have to first ask
yourself that does that violate anything
in my priorities as a Muslim yes I'm not
going to say but but but the people but
the popularity but the Val but you know
is going to trigger a lot of people I
don't care well it triggers I see it
triggers the the people that we're that
we're fighting against right now when
they call it an anti-semitic term that's
when I'm like this is a slogan that I
can get behind and if see if I start the
stream and I start playing music like
during Ramadan we're I'm not doing that
we're not playing music um we're trying
not to at least you a musician I'm not a
musician but like when I start the
stream I start with music because it's
you know it draws people in you know
even though it's not perfect it's not
Quran it's not um it still draws and
then then you get to speak about what we
talk about then you get to give then you
get to you know try to bring people
closer to God even though it's imperfect
is it can it not still be effective even
though I don't believe Christ is the
king of all Kings even though it gets
the the right it shows allegiance to the
right people I think Christians and
Muslims are on the same side on a lot of
issues right now can it not be effective
to to be imperfect especially in social
media which is you know it's the whole
existence of social media is imperfect
that's a very that's a very deep
question and uh you see nothing is
perfect yes you're right even my da
anybody's da is it perfect no we have
some mistakes maybe it's not that
effective the way I say things maybe the
the the the subject that I use but like
I said again it
see anything in in we call it in
Arabic means from St I have to be
restricted in my method of as the
prophet did I can't come up with new
methods of Da I'm not talking about
tools I can use whatever tools that are
to technology that's fine I can use my
phone my camera whatever now what we're
doing this is fine I'm talking about the
method so I can't come for example I
can't say I'm going to give that by
singing it depends what he means by
singing there were companions who did
poetry is a form of so when it says what
what do you mean by that yes understand
what he's saying you know that it's set
you cannot M we know that it's set
nobody can come and say we're going to
add the extra to and make it five no we
understand that but you see how rigid
they are it's like no there were people
there were the companions who defended
the honor of the Prophet peace be upon
Him spoke about to in in poetry yeah is
is that not form of singing I said
that's not that's not right that's Haram
and that's not how the prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam did so you don't do it
anything that was available at the time
of the prophet and he didn't use then we
don't use you know what I mean makes
sense right because what's the best da
the prophet's da that's the best we
follow that the methodology of the dev
and so we have to restrict ourselves
with that but not I'm not going to get a
lot of people to listen to me we're not
we don't care about quantity we care
about quality perfect it's not what the
obviously not what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would do
isn't this what isn't this method
effective in the social media age I'm
not denying it's effective It's very
effective but like I said we have to
draw the line like Christ is King
doesn't does is that really considered
shk yes verbal shk it's not in your
heart but if I say if I say ferris is
King this is unbelievable this is
unbelievable to say Jesus is King is
shik and you you are supposed to be a
person of knowledge well it just amazes
me you're supposed to be and same s
people with Medina and you say just mind
bro I'm the J I'm Ali need da
mindblowing to say Jes Jesus is King is
sh if you said Jesus is the king of all
Kings you can say Okay Christians use
that to claim Jesus is the king like
literally understandable but to say
Jesus is King is sh that's not sh I'm
not worshiping you you're just like what
about I'm a king if I tell the people
watching you guys are Kings that's fine
that's not but you have you have that's
that slogan is very well known and it's
used by who only Christians like you
wouldn't see anybody else but a
Christian would say that and they need
something by saying that and so that's
why it can be it can be true but the
slogan Jesus is king of all Kings not
Jesus is King Christians use Jesus the
king of all Kings every new sh me shall
bow that's what they say not Jesus is
King please understand that but if my
intentions are different and I don't
mean that then it's not sh I'll give you
an example okay if you if you swear by
other than Allah I swear my mother's
life is that sh the prophet said it's sh
a lot of Muslims do that I hear quite a
b what kind of sh it's lesser shik minor
shik doesn't take care the fs of Islam
but you have committed a violation if
you believe that your mother is God of
course that's take sh of this I swear on
my mother's life I swear on my life or
whatever the prophet said anybody swear
but other than has committed Po and this
is the type of sh it's a verbal sh so
like I said your actions has to be two
conditions have to be met your intention
and your act and so here yes you don't
mean chist I'm sure that you don't mean
that but that statement is used by
exclusively by Christians and it's meant
they mean Christ is the Lord is the king
of kings I mean there's nothing El I can
say I just like I I I tell every revert
yeah and I've told sne this as well and
I say everybody yeah these three
individuals sagid shami and
FIS please what I'm going to say is look
like I said be very careful yes you will
go down a toxic pathway everything
become rigid everything becomes
impermissible you know what's going to
happen you are going to end up losing
your Islam you're going to follow your
deal cuz it's going to be like
everything's this that you can't say
nothing Etc and I'm not saying you
should what I'm saying is Islam has um
many things in is permissible these
people sadly make many things
impermissible sadly that's what they do
so what I'm just going to say is for
obviously s I've spoken them privately
alhamdulillah um like I said before bro
I know there's many many uh people
actual people of knowledge that take
Knowledge from like far very balanced
brother alhamdulillah uh who follows the
same methology we do very balanced very
fair alhamdulillah stick to him in and
follow that that's what I'm going to say
I just wanted to make this reaction
video because I found it so sad that
he's there telling him things that
acting as if that is the only like there
is no room for difference uh of opinion
or it's just that's you saying Jesus
king the sh it's unbelievable so like I
said I've spoken to you before but for
you guys watching at home please please
be careful who you take Knowledge from
knowledge please like serious people of
knowledge go listen
to yes there's many many good Brothers
out there so that's what I'm going to
say from sisters to next time look after
to say Jesus's King was said due to a
specific incidence that happened Etc and
it is very very clear what was meant and
we assume the best simple as that uh
that's all I have to say brother sisters
look after
in the prophet sallallahu alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tala tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atam weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra
[Music]
Rewards